of course as a huge fan of stranger
things i want to ask you
um you know about uh the series and one
of the things that i think
is going to be great about the upcoming
series is that uh
sean and the duffers have said that all
the scripts were done
um in advance you know they had more
time to work on the scripts
so i'm just curious to talk about well a
did they give you all the scripts in
advance or were they were they
giving it out piecemeal and what was
your reaction to them and did you feel
like the writing this season is really
good
that's an incredible question because
the first couple seasons
is know that a goal the goal was never
to
film before this before the show was
finished being written
that was never a goal that's just how it
ended up happening the first three
seasons is we we have a certain number
of episodes written around five or six
out of eight or nine is usually what
we'll start filming with once those are
written
and the goal is that they'll they'll
direct
and write at home they'll be home and
that's when they'll that's when they'll
write
on the side and just they'll manage
their workload that way and how it's
always worked out is
is we're about like we're on episode
four or five and we haven't seen
episode six and seven yet and we have no
idea what's gonna happen
and they haven't even written all of it
yet and so the pressure is usually on
and when that happens
usually there's like a two to three week
hiatus where we'll go home
and take a break and during that two to
three weeks matt and ross are home
and they are right king
like non-stop panic writing like
i didn't write my essay and it
english class starts in five minutes
typewriting and
that's never ideal but honestly for some
reason that spur of the moment
uh we gotta get this done it seems
to me like that's where a lot of their
best work comes in
and i don't know if it's the pressure i
don't know if it's
them being up all night all caffeinated
and they just have like
really crazy frazzled brains that can
write really weirdly
i know a lot of comedic writers who will
stay up
into all hours of the night like playing
video games and drinking red bulls
so they can get to that kind of
delirious tired state
and then be better at like just coming
up with random stuff off the top of
their heads because they're a little bit
more delirious
i don't know if that assists them or not
but this year because of
coven there's no excuse for them not to
have the series written completely
when we went in uh for our first table
read which was
february of 2020 so last year we
expected to go right into filming and it
was gonna be the same situation
they were gonna start with episodes all
the way up from one through five and
we'll probably do the same hiatus but
kobet hit and we only had like six
episodes and so
they're like we might as well finish
where are you in the filming process
are you guys because of covid are you
rapping in like june
have you like where what's going on
there's very few
dates that are reliable it really is
more of like
a guesstimation on when we're going to
be filming next
uh when we're going to be wrapping up
when release is going to be
all that jazz because we still don't
know what a day to day if we're going to
be filming next week
yeah i should be filming like next month
for like
a big chunk a bigger chunk than i've had
in a bit but
even though it's coming up in about two
weeks from now i still don't know an
exact date
so because of that there's really no way
to figure out when we're going to be
rapping
i think that they've been able to relish
in their directing in their day-to-day
there's nothing else distracting them
other than what we're going to do
today while we're directing and i asked
them i'm like do you guys sleep at night
they're like literally
we dream about directing the show we go
to sleep
and we have dreams that we just are
directing the show it takes up their
entire minds
when they're making this and so i think
now that the i think it's a good thing
because they now they
can take their focus on off of what the
show is going to be about
and now that they know it they can focus
on how they're going to deliver
and i think it jokes